so this is your third album yes what do
you think of it is there representing
everything you wanted it is yeah sure
like it's a perfect snapshot of where we
are right now which is at least for us
that's how we view albums our our first
album was exactly who we were then our
second one was that and then here you
know it really showcases their love for
big beats in the 808 so we're having a
blast and we're actually out on the road
doing a bunch of like pop-up shows so
we're actually playing it before it's
even available
why were you terrified I mean it's new
music it's like we're getting its people
for the first time hoping that they'll
love it and it got a great reaction so
like our nerves are a little bit calmer
right now what do you talk about
reaction when you told your family and
friends about the switch of the music a
little bit how did they react to that
well you know it's something that I
think everybody's been observing for a
second and when we sat to make our third
album we didn't go out and say let's
make a country album and write it and go
let's make a pop album and just then
let's make the best Band Perry album
that we can we're all about being
excellent doing excellent work but also
being authentic and so you know by the
time it was time to communicate that
direction forward everybody's sort of
already knew that it was headed in that
direction and we're really excited
though it Neil said the fans they're
already singing along here we just can't
wait to get the music in their hands
when you talk about entick does this
album truly reflect your band is this
the one you would say is you yeah I
think for the first time we've gotten to
marry the sensibilities that we've
always brought lyrically and melodically
but we've gotten to build the music
around it in a way that we're super
proud of love our first two albums
really love the sound of this third one
you know and it incorporates everything
like Reid said from 808 bass sounds to
banjos and everything in between so we
got to really not have any rules and
that was a very freeing thing to learn
if you've seen our show your viewers
have seen our show we have a really
energetic one you know we love being on
stage it was what we did before we wrote
songs or went into studios and recorded
and so really I feel like this music
even represents our live show better
than any of our previous albums do
energetically and there's a lot of great
crowd participation moments as well
which we love and we're just really
excited you know it's a time in your in
your life as an artist when you go from
changing from cut a little bit of
country to more pop what was that
conversation between you three when you
decide to make that move you know there
was really nothing deliberate about it I
think we always follow our music in fact
if I die young you know which is the
song that introduced us on to the world
of music right on the beginning of that
moment we had just finished recording an
indie rock record right we grew up on
Zeppelin and the stones and if Ida Young
came to us at the end of a two-week
recording session and it sounded totally
different than anything that had
preceded it from the 14 days prior and
so we've really learned that these happy
musical accidents that really begin to
steer us in new directions are ones that
we have to pay attention to and they've
been really really important moments for
us in the past that was the case of my
bad imagination we started writing the
music has guided us when it was a
two-year process and we would kind of
look at each other during it and like
not really second-guess that just like
just making sure we're like you know
good where we're going and every time we
kind of looked at each other and like
yeah you know we feel like this is it
and I don't think it was that we were
naive to like you know what we were
doing I just think we just really wanted
to move in that way yeah I wanted to do
this right and you think of other
artists and this is not new like we
think of Taylor Swift who's hugely
successful then you see Garth Brooks who
doesn't do too well does that make you
worried it anyway you said your fans
reacted so well to the pop ups just I
think anytime they're an artist is gonna
have a career past one or two albums you
it is about evolution in the same way
that humans are about evolution and
growing every single year you know I
think um I love even this moment that
Rihanna has created with anteye which is
a very different side of her than what
we've seen before I mean from Hannah
Montana solutions like you know at some
point it's very important that you show
people different sides of yourself not
only half of what you love and half of
who you are but the full picture bangs
and all